και έχοντας υπόψει τις δυσκολίες που υπάρχουν σε αντίθε την περίπταση ακριβώς ξεκινήσατε για ν
να πάρουμε λίγό και τα δικά σας φυσικός και μετά ακολουθούσατε την ι ατρικη ναι
τι ήταν αυτό που σας εκανενα απολοσε την ατριατιοι ατρικι και πως προέκυψα δεν κάνω
λάθος μεαπό την έρευνα που έκανα για λίγο για τα στιχία πρηνική ατριη και ταξε
ν κτυνο ακτινοφυσική ναι ακνοφυσικεί ξεκίνηα σαφυσικώς έκανα τη διακτρτο διδακτορικό μου στην ακτινοφυσική ακτυνοβιολογία
μετα ήμουν σε ένα ιστητούτων οι ατρικ ερευνών του παναπιστιμείου του έν που εγίνοντα ακτινο
βιολογικές έραυνες στις κακοηθείες και αρχισαν ενδιαφέρουμε περισσότερο και για ταπου χρειαζόμουν γνώσηση ατρικής και
τισ ξεκίνησα τις πουδές της ιατρικής τις οποίες το τέλος περιωσα και ήταν αυτονόητω μετά
την κτυνοφυσική να κτυνοπιολογία ότι θα ακολουθοσα την ιδικόηρα τις ακτυνοθεραπίες κες θα πογλμε πόσο
περίεργο είναι για σάς όταν γνωρίζεται σε προσωπικό επίπεδο των ασθενή ο οποίος διαγνώστηκε μεκαρκινο
και για να συμπληρώσω θάσατε και την σύζιγό σας αεκανολάθως ναι η μητέα των παιδιό
μου των δυοπαιδιώ ου την έχασα από κακοήθεια αυτό είναι οι διαίτερας κληρώ σε ευαισθητοποιή
αυτόν ακόμη περισσότερον και αντιλαβούματεσε ακόμα καλύτερα τα προβλήματα που υπάρχουν στην αντιπέραν όχη γιατί
είμειση γιγιατρ είμαστε στη μια όχθυνα κριτου ποταμού βλέπο